ah so when we talk about the past we
focus on the things that matter the most
the moments worth cherishing you know
birthdays holidays those sorts of things
until recently we used to tell our story
pretty low-key couple frame pictures
here and there nothing special nowadays
we still focus on the same thing we just
tell a story a little differently
[Music]
most of the shower memories online with
those that matter the most showcasing
our latest adventurer or purchase others
indulged in exotic cuisines capturing
them from every angle before they take
the first bite what about those that
wander the ones who explore the unsealed
roads and stare into the abyss we search
for the unique architecture found only
in the heart of the country surrounded
by nature and accompanied by time we
follow the endless road and capture the
once-in-a-lifetime moments as a curious
species we seek picture-perfect yet
we no longer print a single picture we
need not weeks or years to explore our
surroundings we need only a few days to
create a lifetime of memories we find
tranquility in the moments that never
die the moments that live on through
others just like us and we share these
memories for those that follow when we
explore mother nature explores with us
she showcases her beauty for those
willing to wander and reward those of
the unique guy she reminds us of how
small we are yet how much of an impact
we've made she leaves us speechless
forever one tonight after an incredible
48 hours and more than 2,000 kilometers
traveled we've seen only a tiny portion
of what West Australia has to offer with
a backyard this big it's hard to fathom
what awaits us tomorrow
but if 48 hours an open road is all it
takes to create a lifetime of memories
why away
[Music]